the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today we're going to look at
approximation algorithms for the
Traveling Salesman problem so you should
I hope everyone knows what the Traveling
Salesman problem is you have a graph
you're trying to visit every vertex and
you want to do the so you start your
vertex you visit every single one and
you end at the starting vertex and you
want to do that in the shortest possible
time or distance or whatever the metric
is so unfortunately this is np-hard also
the approximation algorithms for any
constant approximation is also known to
be np-hard so you should have gone over
approximation algorithms in lecture so
basically let's say the optimal solution
has some value V and if you want to
calculate that your algorithm will end
up with a value which is within a
constant factor of V so less than CP
that that is an approximation algorithm
but for the Traveling Salesman problem
the procs constant approximation
algorithms are also np-hard so instead
we employ modified slightly so on the
Traveling Salesman problem we impose
something called a metric so the
important relation here is this one so
first of all let's go through this so
you have a distance metric for sort of
XY or vertices your distance is always
written 0 which is reasonable your
undirected which is this relation and
you have the triangle inequality which
means that if you have three vertices
vertices and you have this looks like
this this distance is always smaller
than the sum of these two distances
which is like real-world of things that
make sense right this isn't was longer
you would just take this path instead so
the distance by taking another node is
always greater than equal to the direct
distance so turns out the metric TSP
problem is also np-hard
so not nothing very great there but but
you can do a constant approximation here
and we'll go through to approximation
today the first the simpler one is a
true approximation and then we will
improve this to 3 over 2 so let's start
with the first one so before we begin
let's define a couple of terms let's
define C of s so let's so what is s so
let s be a path or rather let's say s is
a set of edges
so if you have your graph here your set
of edges could be something like this
this this this that that's set of edges
and CFS is defined as the sum of the sum
of the weights of all the edges and this
actually should be a multiset because
you can have you can count the same edge
twice so you can count this size three
times or whatever you want how many
however many times you want so that's
the definition so now we want to find a
cycle which goes through all the
vertices and you want to minimize the
cost of that cycle so let's say your
optimal so this is this to remind you
the Hamiltonian cycle problem so this is
essentially finding a Hamiltonian cycle
in the graph of minimum weight so this
is or is the novel torreón cycle problem
this is finding the minimum weight
Hamiltonian cycle so let's say there
exists this beautiful Hamiltonian cycle
we just mean if you know of minimum
weight let's call that H star G so it's
the best Hamiltonian cycle on this graph
and that's the shortest path with your
travelling salesman can take and so the
cost of that is given by CF a star s G
okay so how do we go about trying to
approximate this problem so think about
what algorithms you've seen that can
that sort of connect all the vertices of
a graph and minimize costs of edges
remind you anything polynomial that you
have seen in the class that connects all
the vertices
spans all the vertices exactly so Chris
got me I'm spanning tree so in a
spanning tree is following a little time
and it connects all the vertex to it so
let's take some graph let's just go this
one so you have some vertices and you
connect you make a minimum spanning tree
out of them
now where is not a cycle yet but let's
try to construct a path out of this
video and spanning tree so first let's
route it so let's say you're routed
minimum spanning tree let's say this is
the route so you have three things
coming out of there I think that's okay
so let's give these labels so now what
we're going to do is the way we're going
to traverse all the vertices let's just
do a DFS so in DFS traversal you'll
first see one then you'll go down in
situ then go down and see three then
you'll go back up see two again then go
back down see four go back up see two
one five one six so basically you're
ignoring the rest of the graph you find
your minimum spanning tree and you
follow all the paths fold them back up
and just do a DFS traversal and that is
and then you go to reach back to one
setting yeah and then you have this well
it visits all the vertices visit some of
the more than once which is a problem
which will deal with shortly but it
visits all the vertices and it's a cycle
so now the problem is the Traveling
Salesman problem does not allow you to
visit vertices more than once because if
you did not have this restriction you
could shorten your path length by going
to a separate vertex and coming back or
something like that so let's make that
more concrete so at least so in this
case given this triangle inequality I
claim that you can just delete the
duplicate vertices so let's look at the
duplicate one say one two three this
repeats so you read that repeats repeats
repeats and that's cycling back so how
do you delete things so in this case you
had a path right you were going to 1 to
2 and 2 to 3
- and so on so let's run the foreign so
this is following only a tree edges so
how would you delete this so let's say
you find the first duplicate vertex and
you don't want that that's not allowed
so all you do is simply you follow the
path and you bypass it and by the
triangle inequality you know that by
passing it will will never increase your
cost it will decrease it or like keep it
the same so you can remove the duplicate
vertex in this path just by bypassing it
with also remember that this is a
complete graph so a metric is defined on
all pairs of vertices so every edge
exists with some value so that also
calls with a triangle inequality so if
you know it does not exist just make it
the sum of the so if XZ is not an edge
just make it the sum of XY plus y Z so
any case so so you construct an initial
path just by going down the tree and
doing a naive DFS traversal and then you
correct that path by skipping over the
duplicates so finally you end up with
after skipping over the duplicates you
get a 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 and that's a valid
cycle right so so let's call this
minimum spanning tree T so that's your
MST and you are removing duplicate edges
and getting a cycle C let's say so now
you know that actually let's take
another step back let's say ok let's say
let's define let's define a psycho first
witches so let's say let's call this
cycle this guy is C and then you're
going from C and you're deleting the
duplicates and we're getting C - so now
what do you have is cost of C - it's a
validation with anyway the cost of C
dash is less than equal to cost of C and
what is the cost of C if you know the
weight of a minimum spanning tree what
is the cost of 6 e is just doing it
River DFS traversal so what is the cost
of C if you have if you know your
minimum spanning tree
No
so you're traversing every edge on the
minimum spanning tree twice so you're
doing a DFS traversal right so you're
going down you're coming back up it's
like you're going down coming back up
backtracking going back down so every
edges Traverse right so it's exactly
twice T so spring up with a keyboard so
you know that cost of C is twice the
cost of T does that make sense why the
traversal implies that you have every
edge being visited twice right okay so
now our claim is that the C dash cycle
is a two approximation of the actual
house the actual cycle so why is that so
we already proved so this simple also
implies that C of C dash is less than
equal to two of CT realize that this is
not a valid cycle but this is another
cycle okay so now we need to show that
this is somehow bounded by H star G so
how do we do that
well look at H star G what is H star G H
star G is just a cycle which goes to the
optimal FICO which goes through all the
vertices and comes back to the parent
vertex so what you can just so this is a
star G this is the optimal thing now you
can take an edge G here and delete it
and then you will get a spanning tree
because this is your optimal psycho
remove one edge and you get a spanning
tree so let's call that T dash
the patience why that is the spanning
tree because you had a cyclone in room
one edge its touches all the vertices
and has n Satori so it's a spanning tree
but not the minimum spanning tree so you
know that H star G the cost of H star of
G is greater than equal to the cost of H
star of G minus the edge we removed is
greater than equal to the cost of T make
sense so you remove one edge and then
that that is still greater than the
minimum spanning tree so now combining
this guy and this guy
you get cost of C Dash is less than
equal to 2m class of C well you got a
cost of C is less than cost of H of G so
you get a to approximation
so does that make sense okay so that was
a true approximation sounds pretty
straightforward we just constructed a
spanning tree you did a DFS traversal
remove duplicates and you have a nice
path but okay let's just leave it down
but the other thing it seems kind of
wasteful to go through all the edges
when you don't need to so you're
traveling down the tree or going back up
and you're traversing every edge twice
so it seems kind of ridiculous that you
will be doing every edge twice then so
what could you do better well before we
introduce that let's prove a couple of
lemmas let's so first we we we start
with this so let's say s is a subset of
V so we have a graph and you take make a
sub graph so use so you pick out some
vertices you pick up this one on this
one on this one on this one and that is
your s and so you get a new graph which
contains just those vertices and
whatever I just connect them so the
claim is that all that that graph also
has a Hamiltonian cycle the minimum cost
Hamiltonian cycle which is also the
Traveling Salesman solution so let's
call that H star of s so it's some cycle
which looks like this I guess here so
they start off s now the claim is that
the cost of H star of s it's less than
equal to cost of H star of G that should
make intuitive sense because you're
taking all the sum of the vertices and
trying to traverse them and in this case
your ad reverse all the vertices however
this is not this is not this is only
true because of the triangle inequality
and let's see why that is the case so
let's say let's so proof by
contradiction say cost of H star of s is
actually greater than cost of H star of
G
okay so look at a star gee that's a
cycle right so you have something your
cycle and in this cycle you have all the
vertices of s so pick them out and now
so you have a cycle which has cost less
than the optimal cycle in s but it
contains all the vertices in s so what
you can do is now you can use the
skipping lemma from before so instead of
so last time you remove duplicate
vertices but this time what you will do
is instead you'll just skip over this
vertex and let's skip over this vertex
and so every vertex that not an S skip
over it and that can only decrease the
cost
so now you've constructed another cycle
which contains only the vertices of s so
it's a Hamiltonian cycle for s but it
has cost less than equal to H storagee
which means that this can never be true
so that is the reso so the important
factors there that if you have a subset
of vertices making the restricted graph
Hamiltonian cycle is always less than
equal to the cost of the minimum
Hamiltonian cycle is always less than
equal to the one in the original breadth
so intuitively that should make sense
that's a proof ok next thing is
something which might seem unrelated
right now and perfect matchings
so so you've seen perfect matchings in
the context of bipartite graphs right so
you find the minimum cost perfect
matching you do this flow thing you send
all the flow in and then you connect the
vertices with the capacities and
whatever so it turns out in a complete
graph you can still do perfect matching
so what we actually have a bunch of so
let's say you need to have an even
number of vertices right some have a
perfect matching so let's say you have
these vertices and so this is the
perfect matching so every vertex has one
edge coming out of it exactly one is
coming out of it and it needs to be even
because otherwise it doesn't work out so
that's pretty perfect matching and the
minimum cost perfect matching is the
minimum among all such things and you
did this for bipartite graphs it's fine
if you use with full networks you can so
I'm not going to go into the algorithm
for this it's kind of complicated but it
uses linear programming and you can find
this for complete graph and it's
polynomial that's good so given a
complete graph you can find the perfect
matching is what you should assume for
now okay one last thing we want to
introduce is so that's called its Euler
circuits so who has heard of Euler
circuits before and okay so
so the reason we're so okay let's go
back to the what we did before we had a
tree and we were the best way I found to
traverse it was just going down and
going back up and going down and sort of
messy so we would rather want to do it
sort of traverse the thing without
repeating edges so I don't know if
you've probably seen this puzzle before
so you you have you have this graph
given to you and the task is to draw
this graph without lifting your pen off
the paper sometimes for example in this
graph you can start here go here go here
and come back in something and there you
go so you can do that well if you but if
you add on like another thing another
lobe here then you can't make a circuit
you can still make a path I believe if
you had another one you can't even make
a path so how does this work let's see
so let's say forget about the graph for
now let's say you're just drawing so you
start somewhere you go to vertex go to
another vertex come back
Ruben's vertex leave it all right and so
observe that whenever you're making this
drawing you go to a vertex and you leave
it every time you hit over text you
leave it since this is a circuit you
just loop around and every time you
enter a vertex you will have to leave it
what that means is that even though this
is not directed if you like drew out the
actual path you would see the number of
vertices number of edges going into a
vertex is equal number of once leaving
which means that every degree has to be
even so we go and look at this graph
which is that it lobes this degree is
not even neither is this neither is this
neither is this they're all fine I think
yeah they're all five which means that
this this can never have a wireless
circuit so graph can only have an Euler
circuit if it has even degrees for every
vertex and the other way is also true if
a graph has even degrees on every vertex
then it must have another circuit that's
the hard groove it like there's a
constructive algorithm we can use so
let's say you're given this graph for
instance
you would just you would simply go
through the graph you just like started
some random mode and then like go
through again keep following edges - we
can no longer follow edges let's say you
stop here then you pick another edge and
start and so and then you can takes
place these cycles together at some
point so it's kind of hand wavy argument
but it should be sort of intuitive why
you can construct another path given an
even degree you just perform searches to
just create cycles and you splice them
together but for now just take this fact
that given a graph as an Euler circuit
as you can draw it without lifting up
enough if and only if every vertex has
even degree so why is that interesting
so let's say we could add some edges to
our tree and turn it into an alternator
into one of those nice graphs right now
this is not right this is where degree 1
degree 1 degree 3 degree 1 degree 1
through usually all there were odd well
that's not good but let's say you could
add some edges in turnitin Euler circuit
and then you could do a nice traversal
of it and maybe that'll give you a
better approximation so with that hope
let's look at the algorithm so what you
do is you go back to your tree
just like that
so now let's see so this is degree 2
that's good this is degree 3 that's not
good degree 1 this is fine
so degree 1 this also has degree 1 this
is degree 3 I think that's get rid of
the servant does not have degree 3
that's a lot of vertices okay there we
go so in this graph you see that you
have one two three four five vertices
which have degree odd so now we would
like to add some edges to make to turn
this set of turn this into an Euler
circuit or graph how do we do that so
let's call the set of odd edges s
odd vertices sorry so you take the set
of all added degree vertices now go back
to perfect matchings so what is the
perfect matching - it adds edges to that
graph so that everything gets a degree
increase by 1 so if you increase the
degree of all the odd vertices by 1
everything turns even right so you take
the set of odd vertices ok another thing
to observe realize that how many
adversities can you have can you have an
odd number of odd vertices because that
would that would I would screw up the
whole thing where we needed an even
number of things so so why why could
kind of why why is that not possible why
can you not have an odd number of other
vertices so the thing is that let's say
let's say you have some graph and what
is the sum of the degrees of a graph
let's move to a different board for this
so we have a graph G and you want sum of
degrees so di is the degree for all B so
what is this equal to so let's say you
have this graph
so now if you count the degrees of every
vertex in basically counting the number
of edges coming out which means that
every edge is counted twice once for its
descent point once for this end point
this edge is counted twice for here and
here this edge is called counted twice
so basically sum of the degrees is
nothing but 2 times mod afee does that
make sense right so this is even now
let's say you take only the odd vertices
out so you even were to see good this is
good this is good this is not good this
is also not good this is yeah so these
are the odd vertices so the sum of the
degrees of the even vertices are by
definition even even so if you remove
them but some of the odd vertices should
also remain even and so you have the sum
of odd degrees becoming art even which
means that you need to have an even
number of them sense
so going back to this so there's a lot a
lot of branching off here but going back
to the main point here is that you have
an even number of odd vertices so
consider the restriction of the original
graph G to this set s so now we are
going to the first thing we did there or
we considered a restriction of the graph
to a certain set of vertices so you take
the set so 1 2 3 4 5 so you take these 5
vertices and you consider the graph that
is restricted to these five vertices
over there to be 600 just up there there
we go that's the other one
so those are your six vertices which are
degrees now you find the perfect
matching with a polynomial time
algorithm and you get something so you
can now add those edges back in here so
they're leading edges and let's say
something okay so you got three new
edges and now realize that all the
degrees are now even so now you can do
our circuit also so let's call this
matching M so this is a set of edges M
let's call the original treaty and the
new thing that is formed is C Union M so
you're taking all the edges from T and
you're adding all the edges for M so
realize that you can have multiple edges
but that's fine because other circuits
allow you to have multiple edges so now
you take this graph and you find this
Euler circuit so that is basically this
thing so the set of edges in some order
and that order exists so the cost of the
Euler circuit is called C is equal to
the cost of t plus the cost of M right
because you are traversing all the edges
in your graph so that is the cost to our
circuit now my claim is that so this is
visiting all the nodes in the graph and
remember you can do the whole
duplication argument from the port where
so is that yeah so you can do the
duplication argument so you're visiting
all the edges in the graph all the
vertices in the graph you remove the
duplicates and you have a valid path now
let's see this valid path is actually a
better approximation so
so again you will go from C so the C
will go to C - and this will give you
FRA as before cost of C - is less than
equal to the cost of C so now you're
only interested in cost of C so what are
you doing there so we know that the cost
of C is equal to cost of t plus the cost
of M so from the previous problem we
know that the cost of C is less than
equal to the cost of H star of G right
so this is less than equal to cost of H
star G so this guy is less than the
optimal Hamiltonian path what about this
guy well so let's take let's look at the
actual H star G again
so actually let's look at each star s so
as remember that s is the set of all
vertices and that is where this matching
is done
so H star s is nothing but the optimal
Hamiltonian cycle on that restricted
graph okay from a previous lemma which
are just down here we know that H star
of s is less than H star of G so you
know that cost of is less than equal to
cost if G so now let's look at just look
lights are effects now we construct the
matching we take every other edge take
this one you would take this one let me
take this one and and look at Balter and
set also did this one and this one and
this one so look at the blue set in the
red set since it's part of a Hamiltonian
cycle they're both matchings right so
let's call the red one M one and the
blue one M two so I'm not saying they're
better a perfect matching they're not
the minute minimum matchings but they're
definitely perfect matchings and because
they're because we know the perfect
matching is M minimum matching exam cost
of M is less than equal to cost of M 1
and also the cost of M is less than
equal to the cost of M to make sense
because M was the minimum cost matching
you have cost of families less than any
other matching which is constructed from
this again so this implies that the cost
of M is
less than equal to half Kosta okay
what's not right this year let's get a
different board sure so cost of M is
less than equal to half cost of M one
plus positive two since both of these
guys are larger than this their average
is also larger than this right but what
is cost femin flat so M 2 this is
nothing but half cost of each star of s
right because the Hamiltonian cycle is
constructed from M 1 and M 2 so and by
our lemma this is less than equal to
half cost of H star of G so now we have
all we need this is less than equal to
half cost if H star of G and then add
them together you get cost of C dash is
less than equal to the cost of C is less
than equal to the sum which is equal to
three halves cost of H star of G
so that's the proof so there's a lot of
lot of things going on here let's try to
go back and see what we did so we took a
minimum spanning tree and then we try to
remove all the odd vert odd degree
vertices so we took all the odd degree
vertices and made a perfect matching the
minimum cost perfect matching so we
added edges just to make everything even
degree then we took the Euler circuit on
that graph and we remove duplicates so
that's fine that's the easy part
when you do the other circuit on that
graph then you argued that the causal
circuit in that graph is just the sum of
the edges in the spanning tree plus the
sum of the edges in the matching which
you added later so the spanning tree had
already bounded in the previous argument
the matching was bounded by taking the
optimal Hamiltonian cycle decomposing it
into two matchings arguing that those
two matchings are not the optimal
matching so not necessarily the optimal
matchings but they're at least like
they're less than equal to the optimal
so there you went there and so the cost
of da optimal matching which you're
using in our constructive path
constructed Hamiltonian cycle is less
than equal to both of these matchings
you add them up you get that bound and
works so questions I need the steps this
is a lot of branching off and then going
back to get a little bit
yes that is not true by 3 that would be
P equals NP ad else
you're free to go or ask questions
Oh so